[Applause]
okay we're back on overton
okay welcome back thank you welcome to
the panel uh republicans have focused a
lot of their strategy on school reform
and parental rights oh yeah mitch
mcconnell says we're the party of
parents now which has been wildly
popular it has been uh what should the
democrat's response be what has it been
wildly popular is that a big it has been
yeah
specifically related to dei and critical
race theory especially
so dei being diversity equity and
inclusion right and you teach a course
in there or do a uh what is it called
when we do i just we had it here i mean
every corporation does it now yeah so
theory of enchantment is an anti-racism
training but it's different from the
kind of d'angelo model that's pervasive
in a lot of schools robin deangelo the
author of white fragility yeah thank you
sorry uh and
the difference between what she does and
what we do is our anti-racism training
is fundamentally trying to teach people
how to love
which is really difficult
it's really difficult
and we
we understand that
racism and
supremacy is a kind of overcompensation
for an inferiority complex
that that is really what it ultimately
is and if you want to challenge that
then you have to treat people how to be
in right relationship with themselves
and to accept the complexity of
themselves so that they don't
overcompensate by projecting the parts
that they don't like about themselves
onto the other
and
what do you think about just the general
idea of forcing people to take it never
going to work and it's going to backfire
because people will resent you for it
and then they'll be more likely to adopt
the views that are prejudiced that
you're trying to i mean
that's i mean honestly when when they
make us do it it's like i could see
having to do it if like
you know like i had a dui once
like okay you made me go then they made
me go to like aaa meetings but yeah it
was [ __ ] because like i'm not an
alcoholic
okay you got me driving a little over
the limit yeah you're right i remember
it was 30 years ago yeah yeah yeah i
mean
i had leopard shoes on the cop was going
to arrest me i i remember it like it was
there
so
but like why should i when i made you go
to a.a meetings and i would not say when
people stood up and went i'm al and i'm
alcoholic i'm not i'm not an alcoholic
i'm not saying your [ __ ]
indoctrinated pledge yeah but i get that
i had to pay a price because i i did but
like to make me everything that's the
problem with i mean i've also gone
through multiple di trainings and it
feels like it's a product of a
bureaucracy it feels like it's being
shoved down your throat everyone sits
there politely doesn't really engage
except in in platitudes i mean real di
training ought to be a a practice you do
every day with yourself in terms of
trying to be a better human being not
something that you have to go through
once a year to check a box for whatever
corporation you're working for
i mean i honestly just think their
appointments are bullshitting this has
nothing to do with education this is
just a tool for them they don't really
care about education they really care
about parents if they cared they would
have voted with us to keep schools open
to actually fund schools they would
actually yeah america american cares act
they didn't vote for that we had money
in there so that way kids could actually
have free lunch program during the
summers because they were you know
people couldn't go to school and send
their kids and eat there vote against
that they want to take care of kids and
parents okay where are you when it comes
to child tax credit that eliminates 60
of child poverty they don't give a [ __ ]
no they just care about kids
and schools when it's a wedge issue
that's it so now it's ctc now is dei
next year will be something else as long
as it's a way for them to actually win
but down at the court they don't care
about you you don't think about it i'm
sorry
no
this is a
there's no i've seen the 10 years that
i've been
involved in politics in arizona every
year
public schools get cut by the
republicans there every year that's not
they don't care about those kids then so
why do they also the democratic party
became the party
at least at the state levels of school
closures of being beholden to uh being
beholden to unions and of not giving
parents choices to get out of failing
public school systems which they deserve
particularly underserved underserved
minorities and that's a huge issue and i
think democracy they haven't cared about
minorities forever and so it actually
matters to them to win elections this is
where mike bloomberg has been killed
mike has been driving the democratic
party
in the right direction democrats should
adopt every opportunity to give parents
more control over the education of their
children i think democrats are just
harsh
more control i think that's why it's
called the school conservative or
liberal issue we want to have our kids
learning productively in school actually
seeing one another because they're not
at risk of giving each other but there's
no vid there's no school closures
happening right now there's this idea
there's just massive school closure
that's happened around there is no
school's closure what's happening right
now is there's some teachers that are
still sick and they don't have enough
teachers but this idea that there's
massive school closure it's propaganda
it's not true but what about this
broader issue that brett is bringing up
which is
the democrat refusal to endorse school
choice
which parents from all walks of life
from all political parties endorse
because they want to be able to
influence
the schools that their children go to
especially when they would not normally
have access to that because of economic
issues and access in general well first
of all i think parents should always be
involved and should have full access to
the education for their kids right they
should have control over the school
boards they should not be you know you
have a right to know what's happening in
your school and you have a right to say
what's happening there when we talk
about school choice if it was actually a
true choice i would get that but what
we've seen in arizona is that most of
the time the choice only ends up helping
those people that are already helping
themselves the richer better off end up
finding themselves in the better charter
schools and the same time they end up
gutting the poor schools the kids the
kids of color and once in a while yes
you we see some great stories and
they'll bring a couple latino kids out
and say look they're really good at this
prep school but the rest of the time the
actual schools that are really training
90 of the kids the minority kids the
kids in very poor neighborhoods they end
up getting gutted on the altar of school
choice so then why don't we just expand
access for kids who can't afford it to
go to better quality schools that are
that are local that are that are able to
govern themselves set their rules are
independent of of the unions if if if if
that's what if that's the choice that
that they make and that's what i where i
think democrats are just losing a huge
opportunity to win back america well i i
think this idea that uh
[Applause]
no it's very popular even celebrities do
it
i've never understood it there's still
time all right
you